brazil
oil industry shake-up could be
devastating for its economy following
the
uh ousting of the sea of brazil's
state-controlled oil groups
by president balsa bolsonaro earlier
bolsonaro earlier this week experts fear
what greater intervention intervention
might do to the country
following the change in leadership some
regular stocks plummeted losing 20
of their value monday around 13 billion
this also had a negative effect on
brazil's currency
which decreased in value by two percent
what are your thoughts on what's going
on in brazil
so in 1964 the united states funded and
financed a coup
and that military regime
was around until 1985 that was it was
almost
two decades before they had an election
an elected president
bolsonaro happens to have been a member
of
the military regime back then
so it is a very slippery slope in
a country that has been devastated by
the virus
to try and swing the pendulum back to
another military regime and that is why
four members of the board of directors
of petrobras
stepped down in protest when he instated
a
general who knows nothing about energy
as its ceo
these are not the kind of things that
you want to read it's it's why they call
emerging
economies emerging markets emerging
because they don't do things that
developed
economies would and but brazil is a big
damn economy it's the biggest economy in
latin america
and you don't want to see this happen at
all
you don't want nationalism you don't
want these types of trends to start
because they can be contagious from one
country to another we've seen it we've
seen this in the past
and again we were talking about the
economic reliance on
china so you start lining up the
dominoes
and this is this hopefully somebody in
the cia
is wise to what's happening down there
because this is not the way we want for
it to go
in 1964 the united states was financing
the coup who knows who's behind
what's happening now but this is not not
a good direction
uh 64 was it jfk or was it linden who
funded the london linda funded the coup
and kissinger came out
a few years after kissinger came out and
said
we know that they were killing off
dissidents
it wasn't anything like chile where they
killed a ton of people
but there were there were many many
dissidents speaking of
suppressing free speech bad things
happen and they tortured their own
people they killed their own people they
exiled
if you ever exiled you you had that was
a good verdict
but you don't want to see these
developments so what's next if this
continues what happens to brazil who do
they become are they like the next
venezuela like adam said yesterday
that is a risk you don't want to see
that
i know you have a soft spot for south
america you lived in venezuela
you know you got a great spanish accent
um i'd love to
love to hear more spanish on the show we
have we got some colombians and
venezuelans and mexicans in the house
not that mexican sale but
brazil's the powerhouse in south america
right i mean for sure not even a
question
and you know being here in south florida
we have an influx of venezuelans
yes you do bananas there's brazilians
here argent i mean argentina's
a mess i guess just give me your
economic
synopsis and what's happening in south
america how that affects us
here in america because we have our own
issues to frickin deal with and the last
part of that is
how big on the [ __ ] show level is brazil
right now
like well overall economics this is this
is kind of the first shot across the bow
so the person who used to
run petrobras who was ousted was a
university of chicago educated economist
who believed in free markets
and that was kind of the direction that
south america was taking
looking at the example of venezuela and
saying we don't want to go there
so this is not something that you want
to see but at the root
is income inequality and
terrible income inequality in the
favelas it's insane in brazil
oh my gosh yeah yes and that is where a
lot of the coveted deaths
occurred so we're seeing similar
situations play out in peru
mexico and in the united states income
inequality is
an economic phenomenon that that will
come back
and kill capitalism so i i know three
things about this guy
bolsonaro uh and obviously there's we're
learning more about him i know
i know number one they called him the
brazilian trump
right uh he would refuse to wear a mask
and then he got covered
and then you see all these images of
like burning
the amazon in brazil and him
sort of not giving an f of what's going
on there so
he seems just completely
narcissistic yeah i don't i don't know
what the word centered is that
what's your take on this guy bolsonaro
i think that power corrupts absolutely
and we're seeing an example of that but
again you have to remember
his roots his roots were in that
military regime
gotcha that we do not want to see brazil
go back to because you don't want to
have economies that are
susceptible to becoming future allies of
china
and it all i mean i'm sorry but all
roads lead back to beijing
wow and it it's it's an economic matter
and you you care who butters your bread
that's it
so so is china using the playbook that
u.s
has used for decades themselves so
they're they're they're internally
funding coups and they're taking over
i mean you got it that's a that's an
interesting meddling in elections
you're saying they are they are just but
they're saying hey we learned it from
you
thank you you know we learned it from
you you taught us how to do this and we
think it's a great strategy we're just
going to do it better than you because
during the industrial revolution in the
united states we trashed our environment
in order to build out our our companies
in order to build our industrial sector
and what have they done they've trashed
their economy and they've built out
their industrial systems trash their
environment
environment sorry yes so if you enjoyed
this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye